what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i'm doing
what so many of you have been asking me
to do i am about to break down all of
the best and all of the craziest
theories about deku's father and why we
still haven't officially met him in the
series is deku's father secretly a
villain who leads a double life is he
someone that we've already met before
and just don't realize it yet or did he
just go out to buy some cigarettes one
day and never came back at the end of
the video i will be revealing the
absolute craziest theory about deku's
dad that i have ever heard and i first
saw it only recently in the comments
section of one of my videos so
definitely watch until the end the truth
about deku's dad is one of the most
hotly debated topics in the entire mha
fandom so let's get into it if you guys
enjoy our mha content including these
theory type videos definitely leave a
like and comment to let us know it only
takes a second but it helps a lot with
the youtube algorithm and of course if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
quick favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that bell to turn
on all notifications it seems like a
small thing but with the way that
youtube works now you have to do it if
you want to see our videos otherwise you
might miss all of them finally this
video will of course contain mha manga
spoilers i am dealing with all of the
available information so far so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned now according to viz.com at the
2018 comic con the author of mha kohei
horikoshi confirmed that deku's father
will be revealed at some point in the
story he won't just stay a big question
mark forever we will learn the truth
about him eventually at least that's
what the author of the series claims and
with the mha manga officially entering
its final phase or final act the time to
properly introduce deku's dad is running
out in fact as we approach the
inevitable final showdown between deku
and awakened shigaraki the only way that
deku's father can play any sort of role
in the story is if he shows up sometime
soon i mean unless he's already been
introduced and we just don't know it yet
so what do we know for sure about deku's
father his name is hisashi midoriya and
as is the case with many character names
in boku no hero the word hisashi is a
play on words hisashi can be translated
as a long time ago and if used in the
expression hisashiburi it means it's
been a while since i saw you last and if
horikoshi was serious about the claim
that deku's father will be revealed in
the story then deku might be saying he's
a shiburi to his dad sometime soon he
says she possesses a quirk that allows
him to breathe fire and he is legally
married to inco he also works abroad and
that is why he's never around although
we are not sure where exactly he works
or what his job is inco is said to have
basically brought deku up alone so how
often does deku even see his dad does
deku even know what his dad looks like
horikoshi must have known that deku's
father's constant absence would become a
meme and while it is an entertaining
meme for us as readers within the world
of mha his absence has to make sense it
can't just be a meme there has to be
some good reason why he's never around
and why we never see dekko or his mom
talking about him or even contacting him
by phone the most boring theory but the
one that seemed to make the most sense
at first
was that deku's father really was just
an ordinary guy who happens to work
abroad since deku's dad wasn't playing
any role in the story whatsoever and
since there are many japanese companies
who send their workers to work in other
countries it wasn't too hard to accept
the idea that hisashi miria was just a
normal guy with a demanding job but as
the story went on this ordinary guy
theory seemed to become less and less
believable if deku's dad was just a
normal guy and horikoshi wanted us to
know that
then what's with all the secrecy
surrounding his whereabouts why don't we
ever see inco and deku talking about him
or talking to him on the phone why
doesn't he ever come to visit his family
why doesn't his family visit him why
isn't he in any of the flashbacks i mean
working abroad is one thing but you
would still get vacation time and you
would still want to see your family and
stay in touch with them now if deku's
dad left him and his mother and they
were not on good terms then maybe this
lack of communication would make more
sense but there is no indication that
inko and hisashi are separated or
divorced and there is no indication that
deku's dad intentionally abandoned his
family i mean think about it this way
bakugo's dad is just an ordinary guy but
because we've seen him around once in a
while just doing ordinary things we
don't have a bunch of lingering
questions about his true identity we
know that he's just a normal dude with a
smoking hot wife so if deku's dad is
supposed to be something similar just a
normal guy who works abroad then why not
just show him once in a while why not
show him visiting his family or his
family going to visit him or just deku
talking to him on the phone or something
like that he says she would be a lot
less suspicious if it didn't seem like
his identity was deliberately being
hidden from us to the point that it
becomes jarring if deku's father is
still happily married to inco and if he
is alive and well then it is
distractingly strange that deku doesn't
make more of an effort to stay in touch
with his dad and that he never talks
about his dad in either a positive or
negative light in chapter three to eight
we finally got one potential clue for
what hisashimitoriya might be doing
abroad but this is just speculation on
my part in that chapter we are
introduced to an international
organization that appears to be the mha
version of the united nations and this
organization which seems to have
representatives from every country is
debating about whether or not to send
international heroes to help with the
villain crisis in japan now that's all
fine and good but there was one weird
thing about this scene that stood out to
me the people who work for this
international organization all had their
faces hidden in silhouette as if their
identity was being concealed from us on
purpose i have no idea why their
identity would be concealed unless maybe
one of these people is actually deku's
dad and horikoshi doesn't want us to
pick up on the physical similarities if
he says she had some important jobs such
as an international diplomat then the
fact that he is away and can't come to
visit often would make sense and if his
job is diplomatically sensitive in
nature then it would make sense for deco
and inco to not want to talk about it
publicly still even important diplomats
are allowed to contact their families so
this still wouldn't explain why deku
doesn't ever seem to talk to his father
unless he is talking to him like off
screen and we never get to see it but
again that would be strange all in all
the deku's dad is an ordinary guy
scenario is pretty unsatisfactory again
if he's just some ordinary guy why no
phone calls why no visits why no
flashbacks in which he actually appears
all of this has led many to speculate
that the truth about deku's father could
be far more sinister he could be living
a double life as a major villain and
maybe even the main villain of the
entire series all for one now the idea
that all for one might actually be
deku's father has been around for a very
long time i made a video talking about
this theory over three years ago and the
theory itself has been around even
longer than that i just recently talked
about this theory with fellow anime
youtubers zonan who's also done videos
on this topic in the past and who
collabed with me on a video about
shigaraki's quirk decay possibly being
stolen from deku i will link that video
in the description if you want to check
it out as this theory goes all for one
manipulated both inco and deku as part
of an elaborate plan to steal strong
next-gen quirks from children he assumed
the identity of a normal guy with a
normal life he used one of his many
quirks to convince encode that he had a
fire breathing quirk and then he seduced
inco and convinced her to marry him
eventually they had deku and all for one
was hoping that deku would either
inherit his own quirk all for one or
manifest another really strong quirk
that he could steal if this were to
happen with the help of ujico all for
one could steal whatever quirk deku got
without deku orinko ever finding out so
the reason why deku never sees his
father is because after stealing deku's
quirk all for one had no more interest
in him and of course after all for one
was physically disfigured by all might
he had no choice but to abandon inco and
deku since he would have no way of
explaining to them why a normal person
would sustain horrible combat injuries
like the one all for once sustained a
few other points are often raised to
support this theory including the fact
that inco's resemblance to nana shimura
has been emphasized multiple times in
the story according to the theory there
may be some connection between inko and
nana that attracted all for one to inco
in the first place another point that is
constantly raised is the star wars
comparison and the idea that the
relationship between dec and all for one
could be similar to the relationship
between luke skywalker and darth vader
horikoshi loves star wars he included
multiple direct references to star wars
in the mha story and all for one's mask
is clearly inspired by darth vader's
mask many fans believe that all of these
star wars references constitute clues
about the true nature of the
relationship between deku and all for
one something that will only be revealed
at the climax of the entire story
personally i find this theory to be
intriguing but at the end of the day i
don't think it will turn out to be true
if all for one really was deku's father
he would presumably know that his own
son became almight's disciple and the
latest inheritor of one for all so why
hasn't all for one ever acknowledged
this in any way why hasn't he tried to
contact his son and convince him to join
the dark side maybe this theory would
have made sense before deku became a
major hero in the world of mha and
before deku came face to face with
awakened chicagy in the battle for jakku
but with everything that's happened up
to this point it would be very strange
for all for one to never acknowledge the
fact that the single biggest obstacle to
all of his master plans is actually his
own son maybe this could make sense if
all for one didn't know that deku was
his son but then how would that have
happened ujiko clearly knows that inko
has a son and if offer one was involved
with inko in the past he would obviously
be able to put two and two together so
yeah this is a fun theory but if he
really chose to go this route horikoshi
would have a hard time explaining why
this information was kept completely
hidden from everyone for so long but
even if deku's father is not the main
villain of the story he could still be a
villain what if the real reason why
deku's dad is never around is because he
is leading a double life as a villain he
tells his wife and son that he is
working abroad but in reality he is
engaged in criminal activity and he
chooses to stay as far away from his
family as possible in order to keep them
safe from his dangerous life this theory
is definitely plausible and i think it's
more plausible than the all for one
theory i feel like inco would never
willingly get with a villain but she is
a very trusting person so if her husband
is leading a double life behind her back
i could definitely see her being tricked
by it but even if all of that is
plausible it still has to make sense
from a narrative perspective why would
deku's dad be a villain and what exactly
has he been doing all this time is he a
villain that we've already met before
but just don't realize it yet or is he a
villain who has been operating
separately from the villains that we've
been exposed to so far in order for
deku's dad to be a villain and a
compelling character at the same time
his motivations for doing what he is
doing will have to make sense
why would he leave a loving family
behind and engage in a life of crime all
the while keeping that life secret from
his family since he does have a family
and since he has been protecting them by
keeping his distance all this time he
can't be all bad so then why did he
choose to become a villain and what
drives his actions honestly this could
be a really cool twist if it is handled
properly if the motivations make sense
and if the reveal itself is made in an
effective way at some extremely
important point in the story and now
before i get to the craziest theory i've
ever seen let's talk about my personal
pet theory which i also mentioned in
that video from over three years ago i
think that hisachi midoriya might really
be leading a double life but not because
he's a villain i think he might be an
undercover agent who infiltrated a
villain group either in japan or abroad
and that is why he hasn't been in touch
with his family and why everything about
him is so secretive undercover agents
have to completely alter their lives for
their undercover assignments and often
they have to cut off all contact with
friends and family deku's dad's behavior
is definitely consistent with someone on
a top secret undercover mission maybe a
mission that involves international
villain syndicates international
criminals and international heroes and
with international heroes like stars and
stripes now entering the story this
might be the perfect time to finally
introduce hisashimi doria as an
undercover international hero who
finally returns to japan in its time of
need this scenario is one of the few
possible scenarios that could
realistically explain why he says she
has been missing for so long without his
absence being nothing more than a meme
so that is why i personally like this
theory okay it is finally time to talk
about the craziest mind-breaking theory
about the tragic fate of deku's father
hisashi midoriya in that mha video that
i talked about previously i discussed
the theory that shigaraki was actually
born quirkless and that his quirk decay
was secretly transferred to him by all
for one when he was five years old a
second component of that theory states
that the original owner of the k was
actually deku but his quirk was stolen
from him by ujjiko and all for one when
he was still a newborn baby and then
later this same quirk was given to
shigaraki the theory itself was fun and
everything but then i saw a comment that
contained the craziest theory about
deku's dad that i had ever seen a
commenter named gomibako said that if
deku really was born with decay maybe
while he was still a baby he
accidentally activated the quirk and
killed his own father kind of like eddie
accidentally killed her dad with her
quirk rewind deku's mother then made a
deal with dr ujiko to take this
dangerous quirk away from her son before
he accidentally hurts more people and
she covered the whole thing up in order
to protect deku from the heart breaking
truth the fact that he accidentally
killed his own father when he was just a
baby everything we know about hisashi
including his working abroad and his
fire-breathing quirk could just be part
of inco's cover-up in this scenario
inco would have to have been in on the
cover-up with ujico which is why when
she and little deku met up with ujica a
few years later to talk about deku's
lack of a quirk inco looked almost
guilty and ashamed while talking to the
doctor
this theory is interesting because
normally i would never think that inco
would be capable of such deception but
the one possible exception would be if
she felt that she was protecting deku
from a really dark and tragic truth if
she felt that the truth would hurt her
son and probably scar him for life she
may be willing to outright lie to him
for decades for his own good now i don't
think that this theory is very likely
but i do appreciate how dark and insane
it actually is and if it did turn out to
be true it would absolutely blow the
mind of every fan alright guys now it's
time for you to give me your theories
and opinions about deku's dad hisashi is
he just a normal guy is he a villain is
he an undercover agent have we already
met him at some point in the story or is
he actually dead let me know down below
i always love hearing from you as always
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more videos like this in the
future don't forget to leave that like
it actually helps a lot and if you're
new to animal pro or you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet it would actually
help me out a lot if you subscribed hit
that bell and select the option that
says all you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror and
of course a big thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thank you
to alpha sigma this guy is an absolute
mad lad and a disciple of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones that rise
above all other clans including ingrata
algital pate heffa hinokami in water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the spike
eight two two seven kaido might be a
gyarados dylan isidor spidey life canal
tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody hebert
and jeremy cummings finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red-haired ravens steelers on hell crews
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia fat boy games and jessica
rabbit if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you